De entre todas las del mundo, hay una jurisdicción
que está siguiendo con especial atención
lo que acontece en Ucrania, cada minuto, cada
día. Esa no es otra que Taiwán.
Una isla que parece estar acumulando todas
las papeletas para convertirse en la siguiente
protagonista de una gran crisis internacional.
Con la protección de Estados Unidos desde
hace más de 70 años, Taiwán ha vivido al
margen del régimen chino, pero siempre con
la amenaza latente de que finalmente un buen
día Pekín intente invadir la isla.
Por supuesto, esta posibilidad podría desencadenar
un conflicto que iría mucho más allá de
un choque armado a escala regional.
Sería la primera vez desde la guerra de Vietnam
en la que potencialmente Estados Unidos y
China podrían enfrentarse en un teatro de
operaciones… O al menos esa es la impresión
habitual que tenemos, aunque solo sea por
declaraciones
como estas:
La pregunta es, ¿Qué podría ocurrir si
finalmente se desata el conflicto en Taiwán?
¿Lograría China hacerse con el control de
esta isla? ¿Qué dicen las simulaciones de
guerra que se han realizado?
Arranquemos.
Os hemos hablado un montón de veces sobre
ello: la situación de Taiwán es una de las
más ambigwuas de la política internacional.
Especialmente porque la soberanía de esta
isla ha sufrido constantes cambios.
Por ejemplo, y esto puede que te sorprenda,
cuando terminó la guerra sino-japonesa de
1895, el Imperio Qing le cedió la isla con
carácter perpetuo a Japón. Es decir, que,
formalmente, la isla de Formosa, Taiwán,
dejó de ser China… Para siempre… O al
menos eso se acordó. Durante los siguientes
50 años esta isla formó parte del Imperio
de Japón.
Claro que la derrota de Tokio en la II Guerra
Mundial volvió a provocar un giro en los
acontecimientos. La isla pasó a formar parte
de nuevo de la entonces República de China,
un país gobernado por una dictadura militar
y, en cierta forma, alineado con Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, cuando la revolución de Mao
Zedong y compañía tuvo éxito en 1949, el
régimen autoritario de la República de China
se exilió a Taiwán.
Desde entonces la isla ha sido considerada
por Pekín como una especie de “provincia
rebelde”. Una isla que es completamente
autónoma y que funciona en la práctica como
un país soberano, pero que, sin embargo,
nunca ha podido declarar su independencia.
Primero porque su gobierno se consideraba
el gobierno legítimo de China, y más tarde
porque Pekín ha dicho hasta la saciedad,
una y otra y otra vez, que cualquier declaración
de independencia será considerado con un
acto de guerra.
Y así de esta forma se ha ido moldeando,
un país que ha experimentado durante las
últimas décadas un importe éxito económico,
tecnológico y, también, democrático. En
términos políticos y sociales, Taiwán se
ha convertido en el territorio más libre
de todo el continente asiático.
El problema… El problema es que el apetito
de China se está volviendo cada vez más
y más grande. Y, queridos amigos, amigas,
si algo nos ha demostrado la guerra de Ucrania
es que las exigencias territoriales de las
grandes potencias vuelven a ser un escenario
factible para el conflicto militar.
Y aquí, tenemos que recordar que dentro de
las hipótesis de un conflicto bélico entre
Estados Unidos y China en Taiwán, ambos bandos
mantienen una visión completamente distinta
de la situación… Lo que nos revela algunas
claves que tenemos que tener en cuenta.
Para Pekín, el problema de Taiwán es algo
estrictamente doméstico. Como la isla pertenecía
a la República de China y la revolución
de Mao hizo que está fuera sustituida por
el actual régimen comunista - la República
Popular China - desde su punto de vista, Taiwán
es una provincia china que tiene de facto
un grado de autonomía especial.
Es decir, que el gobierno de Xi Jinping considera
que cualquier operación militar no sería
un choque entre países, sino un hecho correspondiente
al orden territorial interno de China.
Y, ojo, porque esta posición es lo que explica
la creciente beligerancia de Pekín hacia
cualquier intromisión extranjera en la isla.
Lo ven como una especie de humillación. Una
sensación que ha sido reforzada por años
de propaganda comunista.
N1(9 de octubre de 2021: Xi promete la "reunificación"
con Taiwán. Reuters)
En cambio, por su parte, Estados Unidos mantiene
un compromiso con Taiwán que no es del todo
compatible con esta posición: en la Ley de
Relaciones de Taiwán promulgada el 10 de
abril de 1979, los Estados Unidos adquirieron
un compromiso inquebrantable con este territorio:
C1("Estados Unidos pondrá a disposición
de Taiwán los artículos de defensa y los
servicios de defensa en la cantidad que sea
necesaria para permitir que Taiwán mantenga
suficientes capacidades de autodefensa" Sección
3 de la Ley de Relaciones de Taiwán)
Es decir, la ley lo deja bien claro: Taiwán
tiene que poder defenderse de cualquier intento
de agresión… Y Estados Unidos es el responsable
de que esa situación se produzca.
De hecho, no parece que tenga mucho sentido
hablar de la defensa de Taiwán si no es con
Estados Unidos. ¿Por qué? Pues… Fijaos.
(T1. ¿DAVID CONTRA GOLIAT?)
La primera pregunta que tenemos que responder
es... Si China finalmente decide invadir Taiwán,
¿qué países participarían en el conflicto?
Y ojo porque aquí es dónde entra en juego
el punto clave de la diplomacia norteamericana:
la ambigüedad estratégica.
Durante años , al menos oficialmente, Washington
no ha dejado nunca claro si intervendría
o no en ese posible conflicto. Y no lo ha
hecho para crear una doble disuasión: por
un lado, la amenaza latente de la intervención
de los EE. UU. podría evitar que China decida
invadir la isla. Por otro lado, la incertidumbre,
tampoco le permite a Taipéi ser excesivamente
agresivo, por ejemplo, declarando su independencia.
Este es el enfoque que, según muchos analistas,
ha conseguido mantener la paz durante décadas.
Sin embargo, las cosas están evolucionando,
el ejército chino cada vez está más preparado
y, ¿qué queréis qué os diga? Si algo ha
dejado claro la guerra de Ucrania es que la
estrategia de la ambigüedad estratégica
podría terminar siendo la excusa de Xi Jinping
para lanzarse a por su presa.
Es decir, si en un momento determinado, los
altos gerifaltes chinos pensaran que Estados
Unidos podría no acudir al rescate de Taiwán
y, conformarse, por ejemplo, con la aplicación
de sanciones, entonces esa podría ser la
mejor pólvora para desencadenar una invasión.
Es algo similar a lo que ocurrió con la invasión
rusa en Ucrania. Putin y su entorno consideraron
que a la hora de la verdad nadie movería
un dedo por Kyiv.
Y eso es, exactamente, lo que explica por
qué Joe Biden se ha “confundido” intencionadamente
no una ni dos, sino tres veces, dejando claro
que Estados Unidos acudiría al auxilio de
su aliado.
Es decir, Washington no ha cambiado su postura
formal, pero el presidente ha querido dejar
clara la posición real de la Casa Blanca.
Quizás tenga mucho que ver que la industria
avanzada de semiconductores ha hecho de Taiwán
un enclave absolutamente estratégico para
Estados Unidos. Las empresas norteamericanas,
la tecnología norteamericana, y no importa
si hablamos de inteligencia artificial, de
Amazon o del F35, todos necesitan los chips
fabricados por TSMC.
[No sé, seguro que eso apoya aún más la
determinación de Estados Unidos.]
Pero, ¿por qué la posición de la potencia
norteamericana resulta tan importante? Pues
básicamente porque la potencia norteamericana
es la única baza de Taipéi. ¿Por qué?
Pues fijaos.
La descorrelación de fuerzas entre Taiwán
y la República Popular China no ha dejado
de crecer con el paso del tiempo. Si tradicionalmente
las fuerzas armadas chinas han sido un ejército
mal equipado, mal entrenado y con pobres capacidades,
hoy la situación es muy diferente.
La República Popular China está haciendo
un esfuerzo enorme por mejorar sus capacidades
militares, lo que incluye la botadura de 6
nuevos portaviones, cazas de quinta generación,
nuevas capacidades anfibias y miles y miles
de misiles apuntando hacia Taiwán.
Es cierto, que Taiwán concentra su gasto
militar en la protección un territorio mucho
menor: 36.000km2 frente a más de 9 millones.
Pero China, está orientando el grueso de
sus inversiones militares hacia el dominio
marítimo de la región, lo que incluye, la
capacidad de invadir Taiwán.
De hecho, la diferencia cada vez mayor de
fuerzas puede ser la razón de que Taiwán
haya reducido su esfuerzo militar durante
las últimas décadas:
La idea de que una China más abierta al mundo
podría eliminar cualquier riesgo de invasión
y de que en última instancia todo dependerá
de la posición de Estados Unidos es quizás
lo que explica gráficos como este:
Ahora, esto es algo que podría empezar a
cambiar, pero lo cierto es que sin la ayuda
internacional Taiwán lo tendría muy difícil
para resistir una invasión de China.
N2(17 junio 2022: China bota el portaaviones
más avanzado del planeta fuera de EEUU. China
da un nuevo golpe militar con su nuevo portaaviones
tipo 003. El Confidencial)
N3(22 de agosto de 2022: Los planes actuales
de adquisiciones y adquisición revelan que
en diez años, Estados Unidos no tendrá significativamente
más fuerzas para desplegar en la región
de las que tiene ahora. La Marina de los EE.
UU. se está modernizando, pero no tendrá
su flota planificada de entre 450 y 500 barcos
hasta 2045, un tamaño de flota que China
tendrá en solo diez años. Foreing Affairs)
N4(15 de abril 2023: Taiwán, muy vulnerable
a un ataque aéreo chino, según documentos
filtrados. Los preocupantes detalles plantean
dudas sobre la capacidad de las agencias de
inteligencia estadounidenses para detectar
una invasión inminente y sobre la capacidad
de la isla para defenderse. Washington Post)
Ahora bien, supongamos que por alfa o por
beta al final todo se va al traste, las cosas
se descontrolan y el conflicto estalla: ¿Qué
podría ocurrir? ¿Cuál sería la correlación
de fuerzas? ¿Se impondría algún contendiente
con claridad? ¿Qué dicen los simulacros
que se han realizado?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(T2. JUEGOS DE GUERRA)
¿Qué podría ocurrir si finalmente la guerra
estalla en Taiwán? No es una hipótesis tan
descabellada, así que en Washington es algo
que se toman muy pero que muy en serio. Precisamente
por eso diversos centros de investigación
y defensa de EE. UU. han realizado simulaciones
para conocer cómo se desarrollaría este
posible conflicto.
Prácticamente en todos los casos se da por
sentado que las fuerzas norteamericanas participarían,
ya que en otras circunstancias la derrota
de Taiwán estaría servida.
Pues bien, tomemos, por ejemplo, como punto
de partida la simulación que ha llevado a
cabo el Centro de Estudios Estratégicos e
Internacionales, un importante think tank
con sede en Washington.
Para realizar esta simulación se tuvieron
en cuenta todas las posibles acciones áreas
y navales y también todos los antecedentes
históricos con misiones anfibias, desde Normandía,
hasta Okinawa, pasando por las Malvinas.
¿Los resultados? Pues… Fijaos.
En la mayoría de los escenarios, Estados
Unidos, Taiwán y Japón lograrían derrotar
la invasión anfibia convencional de China
y mantendrían la autonomía de Taiwán. Eso
sí, esta defensa tendría un alto coste.
Estados Unidos y sus aliados perderían docenas
de barcos, cientos de aviones y sufrirían
decenas de miles de bajas. Pensad que Estados
Unidos tendría que combatir a miles de millas
de distancia contra unas fuerzas armadas chinas
que jugarían en casa.
Por su parte, la economía de Taiwán quedaría
devastada por la destrucción de gran parte
de su infraestructura, claro que China también
sufriría grandes pérdidas y el fracaso de
la operación podría terminar desestabilizando
el gobierno del Partido Comunista Chino.
Los resultados de esta simulación, muestran
que solo si Taiwán no recibe apoyo militar
directo, China lograría hacerse con el control
de la isla.
Eso sí, incluso en este escenario, la resistencia
taiwanesa podría alargar la invasión 70
días.
Vale, ya sé lo que algunos estáis pensando:
¡Ya están otra vez los de VisualPolitik
haciendo propaganda de la hegemonía imperialista
del Águila Calva! Pues ni lo estamos haciendo
ahora ni lo hemos hecho nunca.
De hecho, estos simulacros son, de todo, menos
alentadores para Estados Unidos.
En la simulación, incluso, el mejor de los
escenarios conlleva pérdidas sumamente importantes
para Estados Unidos y Japón, así como importantes
repercusiones económicas.
En otras palabras: da igual el resultado,
nadie saldría ganando. Cualquier intento
chino de invadir Taiwán sería un desastre
para todas las partes.
Pero ahí no queda todo.
Los resultados de esta simulación alertan
de 3 riesgos más que posibles:
Primero, los daños provocados por ataques
cibernéticos podrían causar importantes
daños económicos y sociales en los propios
Estados Unidos.
Segundo, el daño sufrido por las fuerzas
militares norteamericanas podría ser difícil
de reponer. Reconstruir la capacidad podría
llevar años, mientras que China, un país
dotado con una mayor capacidad industrial,
podría aprovechar ese escenario para equilibrar
las tornas. Sería algo así como una victoria
pírrica para Estados Unidos.
Tercero, países como Rusia, Corea del Norte
o Irán podrían aprovechar esa distracción
y merma de recursos de Estados Unidos para
acelerar sus agendas políticas.
Es decir, que hoy por hoy, incluso aunque
Estados Unidos podría evitar la anexión
de Taiwán, los riesgos potenciales serían
muy altos.
(A veces en la guerra ganar no lo es todo.
La historia nos deja importantes lecciones
al respecto. Por ejemplo, e n 1919, tras la
firma del tratado de Versalles, el mariscal
francés Ferdinand Foch expresó su preocupación
por el resultado de la Primera Guerra Mundial,
“hemos firmado un armisticio de 20 años”.
El mariscal consideraba que a pesar de haber
ganado la contienda, Francia había quedado
gravemente diezmada y que podía ser vulnerable
ante un rearme alemán en un plazo de tiempo
no muy lejano. Pues bien, los simulacros plantean
que algo muy similar podría llegar a pasar
con Estados Unidos.)
Y, ojo, que ahí no queda todo, las derivadas
de este asunto pueden llegar a ser mucho más
complejas… Incluso sin que estalle la guerra
tal y como todos la concebimos. En enero de
2022, otro think tank, el Center for a New
American Security, hizo una simulación para
conocer qué podría ocurrir con la industria
de los semiconductores.
Los resultados no fueron optimistas.
Asimismo, en junio de 2022, este mismo think
tank, realizó también una simulación sobre
cómo podría desencadenarse la guerra. En
este caso justo antes de la invasión, el
dilema que le surgía a Pekín era si concentrarse
exclusivamente en Taiwán y evitar atacar
a las fuerzas de Estados Unidos con la esperanza
de que estas se mantuvieran al margen o, por
contra, atacar a los norteamericanos para
obtener ventaja militar e intentar forzar
una negociación.
Lo curioso es que según esta simulación,
al final China optaría por atacar a Taiwán
en paralelo a una ofensiva sobre la flota
y las bases norteamericanas más próximas.
¿Y sabéis qué? Se sabe que el ejército
chino está entrenándose para atacar la flota
norteamericana. Por ejemplo, tal y como podéis
ver en estas imágenes tomadas en un desierto
de la provincia de Xinjiang, los chinos están
utilizando para sus entrenamientos militares
con misiles, objetivos que recrean los portaaviones
de la clase Nimitz y otros buques de guerra
de Estados Unidos. ¿Un aviso a navegantes?
Incluso, según los simulacros que estamos
comentando, una de las opciones que tendría
China sería evitar atacar con misiles Taiwán,
para no dañar gravemente su industria tecnológica,
y en su lugar detonar un artefacto nuclear
en el Pacífico para intimidar a los norteamericanos
y forzar negociaciones.
Esto explicaría también las recientes prisas
que Xi Jinping parece tener por construir
muchas más armas nucleares. Es decir, si
realmente están dispuestos a emplear esa
amenaza, para que esta sea creíble y pueda
surtir efecto tiene, que estar respaldada
por la mayor fuerza posible.
N5(China ya supera a EEUU en capacidad ofensiva
nuclear terrestre. China ya tiene más lanzadores
de misiles nucleares desde tierra que los
Estados Unidos, aunque todavía no lo supera
en número total de cabezas nucleares. El
Confidencial)
(Es probable que China tenga 1.500 cabezas
nucleares en 2035: Pentágono. Reuters)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, en general,
el resultado de la mayor parte de las simulaciones
que se han realizado es que Estados Unidos
superaría militarmente a China, pero eso
sí, lo haría pagando un precio excesivamente
alto por no estar suficientemente preparados.
¿Y sabéis aquí? Aquí es donde el trabajo
del Secretario de Estado Antony Blinken y
el Secretario de Defensa, Lloyd Austin de
impulsar los acuerdos de defensa en la región
cobran todo el sentido del mundo.
Es posible que la mejor y, tal vez, única
forma efectiva de disuadir a China es que
Estados Unidos se asegurara el apoyo de muchos
más contendientes: Japón, Corea del Sur,
Australia, Reino Unido, etcétera, etcétera.
En otras palabras, que puede que en este caso
la sola carta de Estados Unidos ya no sea
suficiente disuasión para China.
Y esto nos lleva directamente a otra pregunta:
¿Qué hemos aprendido y qué no hemos aprendido
de la experiencia de Ucrania?
(T3. LA NO LECCIÓN DE KYIV Y LA VICTORIA
INSUFICIENTE)
Un problema que tiene la defensa de Taiwán
es que intentar replicar lo que se ha hecho
en Ucrania para evitar la intervención extranjera
podría no ser viable. La situación geográfica
es completamente diferente. Creo que en estos
mapas lo vais a poder ver las diferencias
perfectamente.
En la guerra de Ucrania, tanto Estados Unidos
como el resto de aliados de la OTAN han enviado
enormes cantidades de equipos y suministros
vía terrestre, algo que en Taiwán sería
imposible por su condición insular. En este
caso, China podría aislar la isla durante
semanas e, incluso, meses.
De hecho, el pasado 8 de abril, durante al
menos 3 días, las fuerzas armadas chinas
ensayaron cómo realizar un “cerco total”
a Taiwán para cortar cualquier posibilidad
de que Estados Unidos pueda reabastecer a
las fuerzas de autodefensa locales.
Es una estrategia que se ve reforzada por
cosas como esta, fijaos.
N3(22 de agosto de 2022: Los planes actuales
de adquisiciones y adquisición revelan que
en diez años, Estados Unidos no tendrá significativamente
más fuerzas para desplegar en la región
de las que tiene ahora. La Marina de los EE.
UU. se está modernizando, pero no tendrá
su flota planificada de entre 450 y 500 barcos
hasta 2045, un tamaño de flota que China
tendrá en solo diez años. Foreing Affairs)
Por eso, cualquier intento de defender Taiwán
tiene que empezar por que la isla esté preparada
para repeler una invasión en cualquier momento,
lo que incluye tener toda la munición y los
suministros necesarios para resistir.
Por su parte, Estados Unidos tiene que tener
la capacidad de desplegar rápidamente tropas
y equipos en Taiwán o en torno a Taiwán.
¿Y sabéis qué? Todo esto que estamos viendo
es el motivo por el que Taiwán se está convirtiendo
en la prioridad número 1 para los responsables
de la seguridad y la defensa, no solo del
gobierno sino también del Congreso de Estados
Unidos.
N7(20 de abril 2023: El juego de guerra de
EEUU contra Taiwán muestra la necesidad de
una "acción decisiva" para aumentar el armamento.
Un juego de guerra del Congreso estadounidense
que simulaba una invasión china de Taiwán
mostró la necesidad de armar a la isla "hasta
los dientes" [...] EE.UU. debe aumentar la
producción de misiles de largo alcance y
las empresas deben prepararse para las consecuencias
económicas. Reuters)
Pero, queridos amigos, amigas, de todo esto,
del posible plan para intentar defenderse
de China ya os hablamos, aquí en VisualPolitik,
en varios videos que os dejo en la descripción.
Queridos amigos, amigas, la guerra de Ucrania
nos ha demostrado 2 cosas: que lo impensable
es perfectamente posible, y que los tiempos
de los grandes choques militares todavía
no han pasado a la historia.
El objetivo de Estados Unidos es buscar la
forma de preservar la independencia de Taiwán,
y en general, la superioridad militar y económica
de los países libres respecto a cualquier
autocracia del mundo. Pero para lograrse recabar
apoyos y aliados firmes puede ser algo absolutamente
indispensable.
La pregunta es: ¿Realmente se puede salvaguardar
la independencia de facto de Taiwán? ¿Estará
China dispuesta a tomar las armas? ¿Logrará
Estados Unidos construir una gran coalición
de países libres dispuestos a defender su
libertad?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like y suscribiros
a VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.